it is the biggest flare-up between the
two nuclear powers in almost 50 years
overnight Indian fighter jets crossed
into Pakistani airspace believed to be
the first time that's happened since the
two sides fought a war in 1971 over the
Kashmir border region both countries Co
administer parts of it disputed since
the end of the British Empire India
claims the strikes killed hundreds of
militants Pakistan says there were no
casualties tensions have been rising
since a militant bomb attack on a bus
killed 40 Indian troops in Kashmir
earlier this month
India blamed Pakistan for the bombing or
the Pakistani government said it had
nothing to do with the attack and issued
a warning against India on television
even think about the fact they can they
can harm my country we are a people
protected by armed forces and we can we
know how to protect our nation we don't
have any bad intention our correspondent
in New Delhi Soni family currents spoke
with professor happy man Jacob a
specialist in India's foreign policy she
began by asking him how significant
today's strikes in Pakistani Kashmir I
if it indeed has been carried out in the
KP province of Pakistan now this is
probably the first time since 1971 that
idea has
in Pakistan and this is really Patrick
email in many ways
clearly this clearly sort of two notes
higher than the 2016 surgical strike the
2016 surgical strikes was clearly
punitive in nature the MEA the Ministry
of External Affairs called this morning
strike as pre-emptive and not
necessarily punitive so by by sort of
calling it preemptive sort of gone one
notch higher and by carrying this out in
mainland Pakistan you've gone one step
one more step further so you're looking
at an unprecedented military strike
against Pakistan this morning bye-bye
India so I think at this point of time
all bets are off what doesn't really
know or what would be the implications
of this for india-pakistan relations are
equated and I'm given given that you're
saying this is never really happened
before this is the first time since 1971
what do you think is the potential here
for
escalation of you know this this
actually lands Pakistan in a sort of gas
22 situation if Pakistan does indeed
retaliate at this point of time the
Indians are prepared clearly they have
their Emboar airborne surveillance
systems in place they have their strike
aircraft they have their air defense
systems in place so the Indians since
they have the first to mover advantage
they are really prepared for a counter
strike by the Pakistani so that would be
very costly for the Pakistani side but
if it indeed does not strike back at the
Indians after sustaining a strike in its
heartland it's going to be a problem for
Pakistan in many many ways one of it
sort of in many ways calls the Pakistani
nuclear bla positive a so far there has
been an assumption that if India carries
out a strike against Pakistan innovators
out of that say be okay
it would lead to a sort of confrontation
at a nuclear level if participation or
strike like that block gets cold more
importantly this also in many ways shows
Pakistan in a very very militarily
inferior sort of light so I think there
there would be a temptation in Pakistan
at this point of time to retaliate
you